a big part of the job is looking for the
worst two people
turns out I excel at that you a pie
I'm just trying to make a living you
know boost costs money usually
Jessica Jones
I saw you what do you want now
get you touch the wall stop moving call
a slow-moving car way I see it being a
hero just go to target on your back
and their dumb ass this star what if
there was someone else out there but his
ability was to make people do whatever
he wanted
you like my control you have no idea
what I've done what he made me do just
isn't here now he's always here
yes you'd like to invite me in killgrave
leaves a trail of broken people behind
him you made me jump for hours as high
as I could he said I was never as good
as you he's back he's coming for me
that's stopped now
Jessica I'm the only one who matches you
and where inevitable
God didn't do this the devil did
and they're fine
I um this stuff I play the hero with me
hey youtubers it's Charlie they dropped
the official Jessica Jones trailer David
Tennant is creeptastic he's totally
gonna make you cry and not in the Star
Wars way the funny thing about that is
that David Tennant was actually part of
Star Wars if you ever watched the Clone
Wars he was the Droid on the Jedi ship
the funny thing about the ship is is
that it traveled all over space for eons
so we got to be immortal during Doctor
Who and II got to be immortal during
Star Wars but obviously not going to be
immortal in Marvel's universe but still
very powerful the trailer pretty much
answers exactly where the story picks up
it's pretty much on par with the alias
comic that she debuted in front Brian
Michael Bendis is comic where she's
working as a private investigator at her
own business
alias investigations that's the name of
her business that's the the trailer
opens with her just busting a random
head that's how she earns money mostly
for booze as she says it but it's kind
of a post adventure series in that she's
already tried to be a superhero it went
terribly she ran afoul of the purple man
and he totally after up and presumably
she has escaped and now he's coming back
to town she's tried to put her life back
together somewhat unsuccessfully now
that he's come back this is like her big
call to action the other big thing is
that she looks like she's just meeting
Luke Cage for the first time this bar
that they're in it looks like he's the
bartender it's probably the bar that we
see in all these promos that they've
been posting and based on their
conversation it sounds like Luke Cage
either doesn't have his powers yet or he
is hiding them from her just because
he's like seems to me like being a
superhero puts a target on your back so
he's telling her to lay low but she is
using her powers so you know maybe we'll
get to see Luke Cage get his origin
story before his own series this is
mostly gonna follow Jessica Jones Luke
Cage is just a big part of it now
they're always gonna change like a few
minor things about the story just to
make it like a like a tighter narrative
so Hellcat here this is Hellcat by the
way from the comics probably not gonna
get a costume during the series during
this series Hellcat is a broadcaster so
it looks like she's been a little bit
more successful at putting her life back
together than Jessica Jones has the
whole metaphor of the series is that you
know Jessica Jones is very tough but
mentally she is not so the idea is is
that the purple man gives her this big
tall to action she defeats him you know
he's like the big boss of the series and
she becomes mentally tough as well as
physically tough if he wanted to start
making puns you could say she needs to
grow some thick skin that would
definitely be a Luke Cage reference
but they are in Hell's Kitchen and I
know a lot of you are asking if they
name drop daredevil where she's like the
devil did this she's not talking about
the devil of Hell's Kitchen she's
calling the purple man the devil and
just let's talk about David Tennant I
feel like they did the right thing in
not showing his face like he's scarier
when you don't see his face
it's a metaphor for how his powers work
like Jessica Jones even though she
hasn't been in proximity to him for a
long time the pheromones that he exudes
like the the way his power works it
lives in your bloodstream like it
doesn't just go away immediately the
minute he walks away it's kind of like a
biological toxin they're like really
really powerful pheromones so the longer
you're in proximity to him the longer
the effect will last after he leaves so
yes she does have like super bad PTSD
but there's also probably some lingering
effect of his pheromones in her
bloodstream in the trailer she talks
about you know like you don't know the
things he made me do he just makes her
commit crimes using her superpowers and
I know there's probably still gonna be
some confusion about this till the first
episode but she can't fly she's jumping
like Golden Age Superman you know leap
tall buildings with a single bound
maybe not quite that high she couldn't
jump all the way to the top of the
Avengers Tower and in the Avengers tower
does exist in this series we'll probably
see it like way off in the distance but
that's actually one thing that they've
also probably kind of tuned down in this
series like you know they tuned her
powers down just a little bit she can't
fly and they've also probably tuned down
the role of the Avengers now in the
alias comic she had previously tried to
become a member of the Avengers
unsuccessfully she'd been friends with
all the a-list adventures I'm guessing
that's not the case in the TV series now
the Avengers will be there like she'll
know all about them but when she talks
about her time trying to be a superhero
like trying to use her powers for good
it's probably more like in the the
daredevil context something much more
local to where she grew up you have to
remember that these are street-level
heroes so largely they're gonna be
self-contained to the boroughs of New
York where their first series pick up I
think once we get the defenders team up
then their sphere of influence will
slowly grow you know maybe maybe season
2 season 3 of each of these shows and
for those that are wondering they
haven't confirmed it yet they haven't
confirmed Jessica Jones season 2 but I
totally think we're gonna see five
seasons of all these TV shows at least
as long as the actors want to keep
making them it's it's not a money issue
I know you guys are all getting hyped
now this is all dropping November 20th
so I'm gonna try and do is
many videos when it drops as possible
it'll probably end up being like four or
five separate videos for all the
episodes and then maybe like a couple
bonus videos on top of that so be sure
to subscribe to get everything I'll be
sure to do a giveaway whenever it starts
- but if you guys aren't hype already
let me just like dump some gasoline on
the flames here so carrie-anne moss who
appears in the trailer is playing jeryn
hogarth from the comics that is someone
who works for iron fists father so that
is the connection to iron fist now they
haven't cast that actor yet but you can
kind of see how they're weaving in all
of these Netflix series together as
Jessica Jones episode one picks up the
devil of Hell's Kitchen has been slowly
being the [ __ ] out of all the criminals
in the neighborhood so she slowly learns
about him and she runs into jeryn
hogarth who is the lawyer for iron fists
family now in the context of the comics
iron fist is kind of like the Bruce
Wayne to the outsiders like you know
like Bruce Wayne funds a lot of
superhero teams iron fist funds the
defenders because he's super rich so
just because we have iron fist things
you will see Easter eggs for iron fist
but they haven't cast the actor yet so
you won't actually see an iron fist
person or they might refer to Wendell
Rand or Rand industries Wendell Rand is
Danny rands father Wendel actually tried
to become the first iron fist and fell
in love with the person who became iron
fist mother so iron fist was born into
mysticism money and martial arts as we
watch the series we could we can totally
pick everything apart for all the Easter
eggs for the other Netflix series but we
might see an actual full-blown cameo
from daredevil so while you guys wait
for more Netflix stuff I'm catching up
with Gotham I have a flash arrow Q&A
there's actually a gorilla grodd video
that I'm really excited to make danielle
Panabaker and Andrew Kreisberg the the
executive producer of the flash was
talking about Grodd in this King Kong
context with Caitlin snow so I'm gonna
make a King Kong Grodd video next why
you guys wait for everything to post you
can click here for all my Jessica Jones
trailer videos and you can click here to
catch up with the flash from this week
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you